So let's test out our knowledge of this with a quiz.
We're going to go back to our JavaScript interpreter
and add support for looking up variables like (x) and (y).
The first change is that our
recursive Evaluate_Expression procedure
now takes 2 arguments: the Abstract Syntax Tree--and the environment
because we've just established that the meaning of an expression
depends on the context in the World--depends on the environment.
We've already seen these 2 cases before.
We peel apart our abstract syntax tree, which is just a bunch of nested tuples.
We look in the zeroth component for the type.
If it's a "number" node, then we just return
the string value, converted to an integer.
If it's a binary operator, like (+) or (-),
we'll have to do the Addition or Subtraction.
Here, I'm skipping a few steps, compared to last time.
Last time, we assigned tree[1] to left_child
and then called eval_exp on it.
I'm going to do it all on one line now, just to say a little space.
But notice that when I make my recursive calls to eval_exp,
I have to pass in this environment
in order to have my subchildren--the subparts of the AST--
know what the values of variables are.
And since there haven't been any intervening assignment statements,
the environment stays the same--whatever I was given
is whatever I will pass on to my subtrees.
So now I just check to see: if the operator is a JavaScript Plus,
I evaluate it, using Python Plus.
If the operator is JavaScript Minus,
I evaluate it, using Python Minus.
I translate these basic universal concepts,
like Addition and Subtraction, from one language to another.
I'm writing an interpreter.
But what if, instead of being a "number" or a "binop"
our nodetype = "identifier"
is actually a reference to a variable?
And just to remind you here,
I've written out our Abstract Syntax Tree
for (X) + 2.
At the highest level, it's a binary operator
where the left_child is the ("identifier", "x"),
and the right_child is the ("number", "2").
So we started up here with "binop"
but that involves calling ourselves, recursively, to evaluate our left_child.
When we do, the nodetype for our left_child is "identifier"
so we're going to have to figure out what the value of (x) is.
So your mission is to complete the code for this case,
by finding the identifier name,
looking it up in the environment and returning it.